je pense qu on peut dire que yanick
villedieu est devenu de faire un second
sa génération bonjour ici yanick
villedieu qui vous souhaite la bienvenue
à cette nouvelle édition de notre
magazine scientifique hebdomadaire
si j'avais tous mes devoirs nous tous
bien dites moi ce serait l'excellence la
rigueur et surtout la passion du
communicateur drôme curieux et agréé à
yannick est quelqu'un de jovial de
passionnés de rigoureux et généreux
l'épicurien audacieux est en cours
leader naturel jamais de la lgv est
toujours émerveillé fidèles peut-être
pour certains d'entre nous à jean
d'idéal aussi parce qu'on essaie de plus
en plus de dire à nos chercheurs
vous devriez attendre est expliqué au
public ce que vous faites dans des
montchamp en sept années 2020 hors norme
les planètes étaient parfaitement
alignés pour que la fédération
professionnelle des journalistes du
québec décerne à yannick veilleux son
prix judith-jasmin hommage c'est un prix
hautement méritée pour l'excellence de
sa carrière en journalisme scientifique
et les gens qui l'ont côtoyé en témoigne
bonjour ici yanick villedieu l'équipe
bienvenue à cette autre édition du
magazine scientifique et technique de la
radio de radio canada et au fil du temps
yann et que développer une crédibilité
parce que nous comme scientifique on
s'en faire un niveau de fiabilité dans
la façon dont ils nous abordait dans la
façon dont elle allait apporter nos
propos les vieux il connaît 95 % des
réponses aux questions qu'ils posent à
ses invités c'est fantastique dans tout
ça c'est que ça ne paraisse pas donc on
avait encore l'impression d'avoir une
discussion entre deux experts parce que
ils découvraient des choses en même
temps que les autres stores après des
dizaines d'années quand il avait déjà
fait un sujet plusieurs fois il leur
faisait avec toujours cet énervement
comme si c'était la première fois luis g
philipe effectivement là que je pense
qu' aimer les communicateurs
scientifiques et les scientifiques
quand on dure
dew sur des décennies étendue mêmes
spécialistes parce que ça fait grandir
n'ont pas la réputation de service
public en matière de ses ambitions
limitées à des missions de qualité il
passagers avec la suisse qu'une chose
extrêmement importante dans l'histoire
de radio canada ce qu'on avait décidé de
conserver le nom des années lumière
après son départ c'est très rare on a
voulu continuer à nourrir cet
attachement qui a dit que créer au fil
des ans avec liciencié moi ce que je
retiens le plus c'est la contribution de
yannick auprès du public pour tout ce
qui la recherche sur le sida des années
extrêmement difficiles et exigeantes
je pense qu'il y en ait villedieu et un
journaliste reconnu par la communauté
médicale de la ligue et il n'a tout des
conférences médicales internationales et
dans quelqu'un qui pouvait jouer un rôle
important n'avait pas traitement avant
196 donc l'information était et est la
prévention et ça prend des gens aussi
crédible avec une curieuse des
scientifiques il ya des scientifiques à
mon humble avis qui ont trop tendance à
vouloir que les communicateurs
scientifiques ne soient que des relais
et des porte paroles et des techno je
viens les strass et importait que ce
soit des journalistes scientifiques et
paunic mois des communicateurs
scientifiques
il est très polyvalent c'est quelqu'un
qui a la foi on la rigueur scientifique
le professionnel très sérieux une voix
inimitable mais en même temps aussi la
culture tammam extrêmement curieux du
potager cabanès le coeur à ses propos
scientifiques aux expositions d'art
osartis j'aime me laisser les mêmes
allés jusqu'à incarner lui même le frère
marie-victorin c'sur salam et donc il le
plonger dans cette aventure là avec
beaucoup de passion beaucoup de rigueur
je connais beaucoup de journalistes
scientifiques en tous cas qui sont
aventurés sur ce terrain là ce côté
gamin qui loge sa capacité de
s'émerveiller leur fascination pour les
vieilles voitures les taxis nation aussi
pour tout ce qui touche la vie la vie de
terre donc leur potager des paul agnew
du triple saut la bouffe également il
est amoureux de la langue française
était moureu est amoureux de son bicycle
le faisant pas du canada il est amoureux
de sa famille est amoureux de la bouffe
et abobo
c'est un beau roman c'est quelqu'un qui
aimait curieux amoureux et audace
[Musique]
j'ai rencontré yannick il ya trente ans
alors que j'étais stagiaire postdoctoral
à l'université de californie à san diego
il ya découvrez la conférence sur le
sida et y est venue m'interviewer dans
le cadre d'un reportage qui faisait sur
la science en californie je me doutais
pas l'époque et yannick avait tant
d'autres cordes à son arc et ben oui il
ya un hic c'est aussi un jardiniers
maraîchers un éleveur de moutons ou et
de poule un amateur de vieilles citroën
et d'art contemporain un amoureux des
mots il faut lire ses chroniques
potagères en alexandrins et depuis que
puis sa retraite si monter sur les
planches pour lui partagé des beaux
textes de science et par dessus tout
yannick c'est aussi un homme vraiment
très aimable est vraiment très aimé
c'est dans l'humus des mots de miron de
godin que l'amour du québec qui te le
rend si bien sans racines à jamais dans
ton secret jardin ça papa charlie
cherrière un tout petit message pour te
dire que je suis très très fier de toi
moi aussi moi j'aime beaucoup et bravo
pour avoir gagné
prix épousant félicitations car total
mon nom de soutenir ma blonde et des
feuillets velaine et mahina on est très
très fier de tout ce que tu as fait et
c'est important la science est important
d'en parler c'est important vous
organisez surtout de ces temps-ci donc
on est très très fier je tiens à
féliciter pour ce prix bien mérité
moi enfin jeter vue pendant des heures
tapé à la machine puis à l'ordinateur
dans son bureau en pyjama ou en robe de
chambre avec deadline impossible à
atteindre et que tu toujours atteint et
je te remercie surtout de m'avoir fait
découvrir le jazz cher vieil ami normand
villedieu puisque vous avez décidé il y
a déjà un certain temps de marcher de
conserve avec fernand seguin avec pierre
dansereau avec pasteur est avec einstein
même le des gens que l'on connaît
eh bien avec eux qui sont perdus dans
les étoiles
nous vous disons encore une fois notre
contentement vous n'avez pas démérité
vous avez fait ce qu'il fallait
vous maintenez cette pensée libre et
intelligente et toute notre équipe et
tous vos collègues vous dise enfin et
avec grande amitié
bravo félicitations organique pour ce
prix grandement mérité et licitation mon
cher félicitations chromosomes
libidineux je suis vraiment heureux que
reçoivent ce prix là je pense que c'est
un prix certainement mérité
merci pour cette carrière donc on
continue à récolter les fruits encore
aujourd'hui je te remercie infiniment de
ce que te puis à porter et au canada et
au public depuis de si nombreuses années
merci beaucoup fait progresser
journalistes le journalisme scientifique
a traversé le genre dispense général il
a vraiment élevé et vraiment je suis
fier à votre chien
d'abord travailler avec toi et puis
bravo et merci au nom de tous les noms
ça vient d'où
un petit coucou de paris confiné pour te
dire d'abord félicitations pour ce prix
je suis très heureux pour toi c'est
largement mérité toi qui a consacré ta
vie la vulgarisation scientifique à
faire partager ta passion ta curiosité
pour les choses de la science je suis
très très heureux que ce prix a été
remis cette année
yannick j'ai peut-être vers un immense
bravo pour ce prix qui est tellement
mérité et j'ai très hâte qu'on continue
à travailler ensemble et pratique je
t'embrasse nous a prouvé que la science
c'est tout c'est fait pour rêver
donc merci à yannick vit ji on peut pas
perdre quelqu'un comme pour tout comme
yannick là il faut le clown et donc je
vous travaillez avec les chercheurs pour
cloner des yanick villedieu en avoir
plus ici au québec et au canada et c'est
pas fini
il ya eu des arrivées aussi les grottes
astrophysiciens nous a fait parvenir ce
mot du reçu avec plaisir la nouvelle du
prix judith-jasmin hommage offert à
yannick veilleux à titre de journaliste
scientifique
j'ai pu suivre à plusieurs reprises la
carrière de yannick vit dieu comme
journaliste et par les émissions les
années lumière à la radio de
radio-canada dans lesquelles il a montré
son grand talent de vulgarisateur
je profite de l'occasion pour le
féliciter et le remercier de son intense
oeuvre de pédagogie scientifique
si ce n'est bien sûr hubert reeves
maintenant yannick en mon nom
bravo bien sûr et merci et en me
remémorant nos conversations sur la
moune scène par l'ami une scène sur les
joies de la supraconductivité ou sur les
noms de laitue exotiques comme la grosse
blinde paresseuse
je nous souhaite encore beaucoup de ces
conversations et beaucoup de ta présence
dans les médias parce que c'est bon les
hommages mais dans son cas le travail
il continue
[Musique]